[Música]
los incendios forestales en Chile ya
dejan más de una decena de Muertos el
presidente Gabriel borich decretó estado
de excepción por catástrofe en las
regiones de biobío y ñuble también se
registran conflagraciones en la
araucanía y
por cuarta vez en una sola semana El
Congreso de Perú rechazó un proyecto de
ley para adelantar las elecciones a 2023
y ahora no alcanzó ni siquiera el debate
en la plenaria pues se hundió en la
comisión de Constitución lo que complica
aún más la intención de que haya este
año comicios ampliamos desde Lima
una de las cárceles más grandes de
América Latina se inauguró en El
Salvador el presidente nayib bukele
defiende que esto hace parte de su
guerra contra las pandillas Aunque el
país enfrenta un hacinamiento carcelario
y organizaciones denuncian detenciones
arbitrarias detalles con nuestro
corresponsal en Centroamérica
bienvenidos Estas son las noticias que
France 24 le dedica a América y mi
nombre es María Clara calle
iniciamos con la actualidad de chile el
país atraviesa una temporada seca y
vientos que llegan desde la Pampa
Argentina la consecuencia es que se han
desatado más de 170 incendios forestales
en todo el país los fuegos se concentran
en bío-bío
ñuble la araucanía y maule ha muerto una
decena de personas la mayoría de ellas
en biobío y el presidente Gabriel borish
canceló sus vacaciones para ir hasta la
zona afectada Alba Santana nos amplía
entre llamas así se encuentra el centro
sur de chile donde hay más de 170
incendios forestales en activo que ya
han arrasado más de 14.000 hectáreas han
dañado más de un centenar de viviendas y
han dejado varios muertos entre ellos
miembros del equipo de bomberos y
civiles son personas que se desplazaban
por caminos en un caso un camino
principal en otro caso un camino
interior se desplazaban en vehículos en
un caso se calcinaron porque fueron
alcanzados por el fuego en el otro
sufrieron un accidente probablemente
tratando de escapar del fuego los
incendios se concentran en las regiones
de ñuble y bío-bío y también en maule y
la araucanía de momento no hay previsión
de que los incendios vayan a extinguirse
a pesar de que los bomberos han
conseguido controlar algunos una
situación a que obligó al presidente
Gabriel borich a cancelar sus vacaciones
y trasladarse a la zona estamos con
ustedes que toda la fuerza del Estado va
a estar desplegada primero para combatir
los incendios y para acompañar a todas
las víctimas las alertas rojas y las
órdenes de evacuación han obligado a
muchos a buscar refugio en albergues ya
que las llamas han dejado a muchos sin
casa y han forzado la evacuación de
municipios enteros terrible porque
esfuerzo de años de mi hermano del 2017
que no veíamos algo así
el vecinos los vecinos están sacando
pocos cosas y uno y llega la ayuda pero
uno ve que parece que no fuera
suficiente lo único que quiere que
llegue agua que el helicóptero que
llegue luego de conaf que llegue todo el
mundo y chile está en medio de una ola
de calor principal causa de los
incendios este viernes las temperaturas
en la zona han rozado los cuarenta
grados celsius y se esperan fuertes
vientos que podrían empeorar las
conflagraciones
con una nueva decisión El Congreso de
Perú sepultó casi totalmente la
posibilidad de que se adelantan las
elecciones generales para 2023 Y es que
por cuarta vez los legisladores
hundieron un proyecto de ley al respecto
ahora la propuesta murió en la comisión
de Constitución al no alcanzar los 14
votos necesarios por lo que el proyecto
no llega ni siquiera a debate en
plenaria el gobierno sin embargo puede
replantear una reconsideración o
presentar otra propuesta en la próxima
legislatura que comienza en agosto nos
cuenta más nuestro corresponsal en Lima
Francisco Zacarías
tras un largo debate de la comisión de
constitución del Congreso de Perú
rechazó el proyecto de adelanto de
elecciones de la presidenta Dina
boluarte el ministro de Justicia José
Tello sustentó la iniciativa acompañado
de los jefes de organismos electorales
pero los congresistas con once votos a
favor y diez en contra desestimaron la
propuesta y la enviaron al archivo es
así que el proyecto de la presidenta
boluarte que propone el adelanto de
electoral para octubre de 2023 no se
verá sino hasta finales del mes de julio
o los primeros días de agosto cuando el
congreso de este país inicie otra
legislatura con este se contabilizan ya
cuatro proyectos de ley que son
rechazados por el parlamento esta
situación lo que va a hacer es complicar
más la crisis política y social que
sufre Perú según una encuesta del
instituto de estudios peruanos el 73% de
la población está a favor de que las
elecciones se realicen este año y en
cuanto a la desaprobación del gobierno y
el parlamento el 76% de encuestados
desaprueba la gestión de Dina Mientras
que el 89% de la población rechaza la
labor del Congreso según algunos
analistas la negación del parlamento a
la reforma electoral debilita más al
gobierno de la presidenta Dina boluarte
y aumentará el descontento social
El Salvador inauguró una de las
prisiones más grandes de América Latina
el llamado centro de confinamiento del
terrorismo está en un lote que mide lo
mismo que siete canchas de fútbol y
tiene una capacidad para 40.000 reos
cuando en las 20 prisiones actuales
caben 30.000 el gobierno del
ultraderechista nayib bukele defiende
que la construcción será para encarcelar
a las cabecillas de las pandillas
llamadas maras Mientras que el país
enfrenta un hacinamiento carcelario pues
la cantidad de presos triplica la
capacidad de las prisiones Y es que
desde marzo de 2022 Cuando comenzó el
estado de excepción a un vigente las
detenciones se dispararon desde ciudad
de Guatemala a nuestro corresponsal para
Centroamérica Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
nos hizo el balance de la política
después de 10 meses de régimen de
excepción en El Salvador nayib bukele Ha
logrado su cometido su empresa de
desestructurar por completo a las
pandillas precisamente el diario El Faro
uno de los medios salvadoreños
reconocidos por su periodismo
investigativo muy crítico de bukele y
cuyas investigaciones le han valido el
premio Gabo el premio rey de España
publicó hoy una investigación en la que
aseguran que en El Salvador ya no hay
pandillas por lo menos como se conocía
anteriormente esta investigación muestra
que en San Salvador todas las zonas
donde se encontraban las pandillas Mara
Salvatrucha Trece 13 las dos facciones
de barrio 18 que son los Sureños y los
revolucionarios y otras pandillas
menores pues ya no tienen y ya no operan
allí ya no tienen influencia y en 14
comunidades de todo el país que estas
pandillas controlaban todas las
fronteras Pues ahora se respira aire de
Paz Ya no hay extorsiones lo que quiere
decir que se ha cumplido ese cometido el
presidente bukele Claro está con graves
denuncias al de los Derechos Humanos
está buscando Joe biden una nueva
aspiración a la presidencia de Estados
Unidos Aunque no confirmó nada de esto
el mandatario hizo un meeting donde
miembros del partido demócrata corearon
cuatro años más ibai de no guardo
Silencio Al contrario le preguntó a la
multitud si estaba con él a lo que los
cánticos continuaron el evento sucedió
en Filadelfia donde habló antes el
comité nacional demócrata allí el
presidente defendió sus políticas de
empleo y las inversiones federales en
materia de Obras Públicas atención
médica y medio ambiente
[Música]
hasta este mes hemos creado 12 millones
de nuevos empleos creamos más nuevos
empleos en dos años que cualquier
presidente en sus términos completos eso
es gracias a ustedes los dos años más
fuertes con diferencia
3,4% de desempleo el más bajo en 54 años
Tengo la intención de hacerlo hacer más
así que permítanme hacerles una pregunta
simple están conmigo me postulé para
presidente gracias
el pentágono sostiene que detectaron un
segundo globo aerostático de China esta
vez sobrevolando América Latina el
portavoz de la entidad estadounidense el
general de brigada Patrick Rider Indicó
que no parece dirigirse a Estados Unidos
Aunque afirma que es un objeto espía
previamente el diario La Nación de Costa
Rica publicó un artículo explicando que
se vio un objeto Volador sobre el
Pacífico y la gran área metropolitana
del país esto ocurre después de que el
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony blinquen cancelara su viaje a
Beijing tras detectar un primer globo
chino en el estado de Montana así se
pronunció blinken sobre ese objeto la
presencia de este globo de vigilancia en
el espacio aéreo estadounidense es una
Clara violación de la soberanía de
Estados Unidos y del derecho
internacional es un acto irresponsable y
la decisión de la República Popular de
China de llevar a cabo esta acción en
vísperas de mi visita prevista va en
detrimento de las conversaciones que
estábamos dispuestos a otra de las
noticias en Estados Unidos es que un
sexto policía fue destituido al estar
involucrado presuntamente en la muerte
de la afroamericano tibenicos en un
comunicado el departamento de la policía
de la ciudad de Memphis precisó que el
oficial Preston hemfield violó las
políticas del departamento sobre
conducta personal veracidad y normas
sobre el uso de teiser A diferencia de
los otros cinco agentes despedidos
hanfield es blanco y la policía agregó
que otro oficial no identificado también
fue suspendido
así llegamos al final de las noticias
los invitamos a que se conecten con
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]